the collapse of cryptocurrency exchange
FTX has rattled the crypto world and set
off a scramble to find billions of
missing dollars and to make things even
more complicated cryptocurrency
exchanges are so new the bankruptcy
courts haven't yet had to sort out
complex legal questions surrounding
their collapse so here are three things
to know about ftx's bankruptcy case
first there's a growing jurisdiction
battle over where bankruptcy proceedings
should take place the U.S or the Bahamas
on November 11th the day that FTX
founder Sam bankman freed resigned FTX
and more than 130 corporate Affiliates
filed for chapter 11 bankruptcy in
Delaware but the Bahamas government
appears to be challenging that venue on
November 15th a Bahamas court-appointed
Liquidator filed for chapter 15
bankruptcy in New York on behalf of FTX
digital markets and he essentially asked
to move some of the legal proceedings to
the Bahamas he argued that the Bahamas
has jurisdiction over FTX digital and
other entities that were operated by SPF
out of a huge office complex in Nassau
it's not uncommon for the Bahamas to
oversee the bankruptcy of a
bahamas-based company but ftx's new
leaders have criticized the move calling
it a blatant attempt to avoid the
supervision of the court in Delaware and
keep the FTX subsidiary in the Bahamas
isolated from the rest of the company
they argue that all the proceedings
should take place in a single Bankruptcy
Court the one in Delaware so that the
company can secure its assets a hearing
over the venue dispute is scheduled for
Monday
speaking of ftx's New Management it
looks like we'll be hearing a lot from
John J Ray he's the new FTX CEO and he
has Unwound Enron and other major
corporate failures he has already become
a key figure in the proceedings and he
drove headlines with the court filing on
Thursday in it he pointed out that he
has over 40 years of legal and
restructuring experience and that never
in his career had he seen such a
complete failure of corporate controls
and such a complete absence of
trustworthy financial information the
filing went on to paint a picture of
ftx's chaotic finances and regarding the
balance sheets of FTX and its
subsidiaries Rey repeatedly said I do
not have confidence in them an email
sent to bankman Freed for comment
bounced back ftx's new management is now
scrambling to figure out just how much
money the company even has
so what does this all mean for customers
there are still a lot of unknowns this
is the largest collapse of a
cryptocurrency exchange ever and it's
being handled by a bankruptcy system
that hasn't yet figured out crypto legal
experts say that's because this issue is
so new the courts haven't yet had a
chance to decide complex legal issues
like the question of who owns digital
currencies is it the cryptocurrency
exchange or the customer who made a
deposit FTX has said that the number of
creditors in bankruptcy could top one
million legal experts say it'll probably
be a long time before FTX customers have
a better idea of what they'll get back
and what legal recourse if any they may
have against SBF and others that
reportedly knew of the misuse of FTX
customer funds